what we see is that there are six
different length fasts that people can
benefit from and i'll go through them
very quickly intermittent fasting 13 to
15 hours great i mean that's what so
many people are doing
and what it's really great i mean the
research is all i mean you don't have to
go far to see amazing research there but
if you want to you know lose weight you
want to increase growth hormone you want
to increase testosterone um you want
more ketones for better mental clarity
13 to 15 hours is amazing 17 hours we
start to to
trigger something called the tophagee
autophagy is where your brilliant body
looks within and it says okay no food's
coming
so i better be a better version of
myself and so those cells start to
repair they throw they kick out viruses
pathogens they kick out metals they kill
cells that are not gonna that are gonna
turn into cancer cells like you at 17
hours of fasting you go into this crazy
repair phase
at 24 hours your whole microbiome
reboots and you get stem cells in your
gut so if you've been on birth control
antibiotics mouth toxicity
even removing breast implants all of
that destroys the microbiome so throw
some 24-hour fast at it and now you're
repairing you're getting that repair 36
hours you're burning more you start to
really go after stubborn fat
48 hours and you reset dopamine pathways
in the brain so you start to experience
more joy and then 72 hours you reboot
your whole immune system
wow i do not know
a supplement a drug
anything that can accomplish that like
fasting
that's why i love it
wow how often would you recommend
more extreme ones beyond the 13 to 15
because to me that's where i fall i sort
of fall in the 12 to 15 even 16 is kind
of hard to get to
um i usually just like use 12 for sure
um but then the longer ones
oh we're gonna get you to do a longer
one you're gonna love it
so here's here's the way it works is
that if you look i look at the cycle
like a circle
on the first part of our cycle like day
one to day ten
um again any of those fasts i talked
about are great yeah ovulation period
you really 15 hours is good but we don't
want to stimulate autophagy during
ovulation because what can happen is a
lot of those metals can get
redistributed into the brain into the
body um some people have worse detox
symptoms so i like to keep the fast for
women under 15 hours during ovulation
after ovulation those four days
afterwards you can go into if you want
to throw a three-day water fast at it
great
and then the week before your period no
fasting which is
really hard because
yeah like eight hour like it doesn't
matter just like you don't not above 13
you really want to keep it under 13.
so if 13 is easy and you're like i can
just do it it's super simple go for it
but
what you don't want to do is raise
cortisol
so for most people 10
8 10 hours of fasting is going to keep
cortisol where we want it okay okay what
about um what about where we slot
workouts in with this cycle and um
should you work out fasted
uh yeah does that fit in you know that's
this is this is a controversial uh topic
i i mean i i literally like it it's
something in my head that's a
controversy because i'm like fasting is
a stressor workout to stressor like i'm
trying to take care of my adrenals i'm
trying to take care of my hormones
trying to not slow metabolism down
trying to not slow my thyroid down like
there's so many things that i'm thinking
of and i'm like wait but there's so much
benefits from it and they talk about
there being a lot of really good
positives with like
training in a fasted state so yeah so
where do you stand
yeah so this is what i found is again
the front half day one i'll just use the
days because it's easiest it did we
start in the hormone world we throw all
these fancy terms around ludial and
follicular and i think for the
layperson they're just like i don't know
what that means so um i like to make it
a little more clear day one to day 10
you can
run a marathon you can
take on a new crossfit class you can
up your workout you're going to do great
during ovulation
you've got testosterone and so use
testosterone
to your muscle advantage so yeah so
start upping your strength training
during ovulation if you want to do more
cardio during those first 10 days great
more strength training during ovulation
then when you come out of ovulation
again we have that weird little dip of
hormones you can go back into pushing
your workouts and and really you could
do more hit training you could do more
cardio you can kind of do whatever you
want and then the week before your cycle
stop pushing it yoga
pilates go for a hike
so we when you look at when you work
with a trainer or you create your own
workout plan it's usually done on a
weekly basis like okay
i'll run on monday i'll strength train
on tuesday
for women we should do it on a monthly
basis we shouldn't do it on a weekly
basis because if we map it to our
hormones like if you're trying to build
muscle
flip and do it drain ovulation you've
got testosterone to help you really
power through that
but we don't look at it that way as far
as i know okay what about um where
coffee fits in i always have to ask
about coffee because i love coffee yeah
i did i stopped coffee for two and a
half months last summer when i lost my
cycle when my like my lymph nodes were
so swollen and i could feel them getting
worse when i drank coffee like after a
cup i was like oh i can feel it so i
mean like i was obviously a pretty high
load of toxicity in my body but yeah
yeah but um but i'm very curious about
it and then also maybe adding in a
perspective on
um
you know adding fat to your coffee and
if you know kind of being in a fasting
mimicking state is
beneficial or not and maybe the
difference between weight loss and
autophagy and cellular health and
longevity
okay let's start with coffee and if i
forget the rest you'll have to yeah i
really can't obviously i want to know a
lot of things no i love it it's such
it's i think
there the whole world can benefit from
fasting not just women um you know we're
talking about women but obviously men
rock fasting
but what happens is we get into the path
like you were saying like there's all
these amazing things i can do for my
health and we get in that path and then
we get stuck and we just pushed the
health tool out and go ah it didn't work
for me but there's a rhythm to all of
this so
with coffee my first question is were
you doing clean coffee do you know if
you were doing like chemical free mold
free coffee i always make sure i drink
like
mold free clean organic like you know i
mean i think an easy one to probably go
to would be like a bulletproof coffee
i'm like brand bulletproof brand because
you know it's advertised and supposed to
be
low mold and toxicity so yeah so i've of
all the research i've done on coffee i
it the only time coffee doesn't do well
for us is when it's toxic
so
uh not to name any
any names of uh coffee shops but uh you
know the like the mainstream ones
are are there chemicals in a cup so
every time you're drinking that you're
giving yourself a toxic dump that kind
of coffee i do not advocate for clean
coffee is a fasters like dream
because when we take a good clean cup of
coffee there's and we put like mct oil
in it put some grass-fed butter if
that's your jam
put in some i put like raw cream i'll do
like not organic raw cream so you're
getting probiotics and enzymes in it
it's a bit like a meal and it won't
spike your blood sugar it typically
doesn't pull you out of a fasted state
and what happens is it'll actually help
you make ketones quicker
the coffee itself can actually put you
into a tophagi quicker
so
there's not a lot wrong with coffee for
fasting when you get those ketones it's
ketones go up into the brain and they
kill hunger so now you wake up and
you're like oh
i was gonna go till noon today fasting
but it's nine o'clock and i'm hungry
what am i gonna do
have a cup of coffee with some mct oil
in it you could put a little bit of raw
cream in it not this is not coffee mate
you're not putting like
toxic creamer in there
and all of a sudden wait wait 20 30
minutes and you'll see that your hunger
goes away because it moves you into that
fasted fat burning state much easier
right and when you say raw because i've
been i've been sort of watching a lot of
different things talking people talking
about um like unpasteurized raw cheese
and milk and things like that but it's
very hard to get it's illegal in states
it's right
i mean don't worry you can buy
cigarettes but you can't buy you know
raw milk right is that what you mean
yeah
yeah so raw so what happens when we
pasteurize milk is we kill all the good
in it
so if you walk into your let's say
grocery store and all of a sudden you're
like oh i'm going to go organic
pasteurized i heard that you know i
don't want the antibiotics and the
hormones that are in that milk so i'll
go go organic well that's awesome
because you're not getting the toxic
load but you're still putting a dead
food into your cup of coffee
when you go raw you've got the
probiotics you've got the enzymes in
them you put it in your in your coffee
you're feeding your microbiome you're
breaking down any you know whatever food
you're going to eat later that day it
now becomes a health food
why is it
why is it controversial
well maybe
why a lot of things are controversial
because people learn how good they are
for you and there's some conspiracy
against muting us from our pure
potential i don't know
you know amen i am high fiving you on
that one you know synthetic painkillers
are fine but psychedelics aren't right
like there's just like a you know stuff
from the ground so it's right you know i
have a lot of opinions on that but how
do you get it like because i mean i'm in
indiana with my parents right now and i
was like oh i want to get some raw dairy
and um we were like googling it and
looking it up and you can't get it i was
at a farmer's market last weekend and i
asked a farmer about raw dairy and he's
like it's like illegal you know you have
to pasteurize it could have some bad
bacteria from unlike so basically the
sourcing matters and
you know so how do you get it like what
if you're in a state
that it's i mean because almost all
states i think it's illegal the the
company yeah well i'm in california so
it's we seem to be able to get it here
so at our money yeah california's very
own that was the one that we saw
california has um looser rules on it so
yeah can you ship it in can you like is
it a california company where you can
order some raw yeah it's called raw
farms
and uh you can look them up online if
you have trouble finding them just let
me know and i'll send you the link
[Music]